joining me now is miley hemingway seen
senior editor at the federalist and the
fox news contributor molly um you know i
know you always have some kick ass you
know analysis but i think we're missing
that he had bruno mars on there he had
taylor swift i mean we should be
celebrating this right
it is just amazing to see how much the
state department has been pushing this
spotify playlist
and it's not that i don't think anthony
blinken has maybe good taste in music i
just have no basis to believe that this
is actually his spotify playlist like i
don't think a grown man is listening to
taylor swift and olivia rodrigo
i don't find it a very credible list for
blinken who is supposedly a really good
guitar player you don't see that as
evidenced in the list but more
importantly like you said we have all
these major issues that our country is
facing and lincoln has had a really
rough go of things he had that really
rough start with his first meeting with
the chinese officials where they
embarrassed him and he came off weak in
general weakness is a thing that we're
dealing with
i'm not sure spotify playlist is the way
to counter that image of weakness
globally no seriously especially when
you have putin that is continuing to
flex his muscles right now for
administration that had so much
experience and was going to say that
america was back it seems like america's
kind of gone right now it seems like all
the enemies that feared us and respected
us are now back to the obama days but
maybe that's what they wanted
i don't think everything the biden
administration has done is awful in
foreign policy but he has quite a few
failures you know what happened in
afghanistan was just a horrible thing
that the entire country feels dishonor
over and weakness like the weakness that
the biden administration has kind of
presented on a platter can be
provocative you might remember that
putin was not invading countries during
the trump era he took advantage of you
know neocon foreign policy basically to
to do his previous incursions whether
that was under obama or now he seems to
be threatening with biden he also at the
tail end of the george w bush presidency
tried that too um we have really serious
issues and the state department keeps
pushing out this spotify list it just
makes you nervous because they're not
just doing a bad job they keep doing
these things that are not serious at all
yeah it seems like they're always
concerned about the image
of the secretary and the administration
in general you know often the former
president was criticized uh of his words
and his tone but you know when you look
at the president former president uh
what he said versus what he did
policy-wise there was a big difference
especially when it came to russia very
tough on russia probably the most
sanctions that russia was received in a
modern time but when his words it was
like let's work together let's work
together the bite administration seems
to have this flip talk tough act weak
yeah and president trump had a really
impressive foreign policy i think that
that has not been
he has not gotten enough credit for how
much good he did in moving us away from
some of our interventionism that was
causing problems and this is something
where you know biden has a lot of
problems on his watch and um
we'd like to see the national security
council and other entities engaged in
foreign policy caring much more about
actual action and less about image and
if they are going to care about image
please put out a better spotify playlist
than one that seems like it was focus
grouped for hipsters yeah because there
was no hip-hop and i was a little sad
about that anyway molly thanks so much
for coming on hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else